whether we're talking about small
mistake or big mistake let's say on a go
ofl lap the first corner you have this
little bit of a lock up of the tire you
know you lose the line a bit you have to
be able to forget that immediately
because if you keep thinking about it
that I need to recover it in the next
Corners that's your lab done ruined
nothing good will come out of it so it's
a certain skill that you need in this
boort to be able to deal with those
mistakes whether it's a small or big one
and I think in that thing for me what's
the most important is to be um like
self- honest and accepting it okay yeah
I messed up and what's the best thing
next that I can do uh usually it is to
understand the mistake what happened how
can I prevent it from happening again
and then move on then don't look back